housing associations are the best type
of tenant i don't think i'm ever going
to rent my houses out every time i buy a
house i don't think i'm going to rent it
out now to a normal tenant
housing associations all the way
supported living yes please if you are
wanting to get into property and you
don't know about housing associations
and you don't understand what supported
living is and how it's massively
affecting the market the economy helping
people as well if you don't understand
this then really you need to watch this
video to the end and understand it so
i'm going to be talking about how
housing associations have completely
changed the business model
of property investing here in the uk and
how you can make a massive
massive scalable profitable property
business by doing this so firstly why
don't you go ahead and just hit the like
button because i put out content like
this every single not quite every single
day but pretty much so hit the like
button and it will it will show me that
this is actually being listened to and
this is actually helping people and
incentivize me to keep on going so hit
like let's make the video go viral let's
change the way property investing is
done what's a housing association what
is assisted and supported living what
does it mean how does it apply to you so
let me explain you're going to find out
why this is going to massively benefit
you in a moment as a property investor
but let me just explain this okay
there are kids
that go into foster care
and they are completely dependent on
their carers however when those kids
get to like 16 18 years old and suddenly
they're no longer in the care system
because the carers don't get paid for
them anymore
these kids are now
out on their own in the big bad world
they haven't got parents they're not
necessarily able to just be on their own
completely but at the same time they are
adults so they don't need to be in care
that in between stage
is where there will be a need
for supported living supporting living
supported living is where you're living
sort of codependently so you're
independent but not completely
independent there's someone there's
someone there that can keep an eye on
you kind of look after you this is not
just for kids in care this is also for
old people if you're an old person
you're not quite ready to have to go to
a care home okay you don't want to go
and live in a care home you want to stay
at home
but you're in that sort of co-dependent
stage where you do need someone to be
coming a couple few times a day maybe
even living with you
that's the same same with prisoners
people that come out of prison and
they're not that they're not quite ready
to just come back in get a job so there
are there are certain ex-offenders
vulnerable women maybe women that have
been abused and now they just so so
there's a massive need the government
and the council have seen for supported
living now as a result of that housing
associations are being set up like crazy
so
individuals are setting up companies
called housing associations and these
housing associations say to the council
we will
provide
supported living and the councils pay
these housing associations a freaking
fortune like i'm talking crazy money
for ex-prisoners
some of these ex-prisoners that come out
the housing associations for providing
accommodation and for assisting and
supporting these ex-prisoners they'll
pay them 11 000 pounds a week say one
offender
crazy
crazy for some of these vulnerable women
for people that were homeless
and are now kind of again at that point
there are certain people that the
council will pay housing associations a
fortune to house and assist these people
right so what should you do should you
go set up a housing association
maybe that's what my
my parents did my mother and
father-in-law have set up a housing
association
very successfully and there's a lot of
people that are setting up housing
associations and then what they're doing
is they're getting paid direct from the
council a fortune for looking after for
offering supported living to these
co-dependent people however
i'm a property investor right i don't
want to go and set up a housing
association it's not my calling i
haven't got the time i haven't got the
inclination what do i have i have
properties so what am i doing i'm
renting my houses
to housing associations and the housing
associations because they're getting
paid so much money by the councils
they're paying me a fortune all my hmos
now i'm handing over to how to housing
associations because what's the point of
me renting out a [ __ ] like either
housing in personal road i'm renting
this house out room by room by room by
room by room
i'm renting this house out if i did it
as a single let i'd get paid
700 quid
all right if i just rented the house out
or family
700 quid if i rent it out as a hmo
i'm gonna get two thousand pounds a
month
but i'm gonna have to pay the utility
bills so i'm only gonna be left with
1500
but then i'm gonna have to have the
hassle of managing the hmo finding the
tenants
having jimmy and sarah call me up
telling me that arguing about whose turn
it is to do the dishes i'm not
interested
okay so i'm having to manage the hmo so
i'm having to pay a management company
so i'm only going to be left with maybe
1200 quid so i'm renting this house out
as a hm i'm getting 1200 pound it's
better than 700 pound but i'm getting
1200 or
i could pass it to a housing association
and get 1500 a month
and they'll pay the bills
and they're being paid by the council to
have to
manage like i'm doing nothing i'm
getting 1500 a month it's completely
systemized it's completely automated and
these housing associations are signed in
five year contracts
i'm in i'm ready to sign more so if
you're watching this and you're a
housing association provider
come find me i've got houses all over
the place i'm desperately looking for
you guys if you're a property investor
that's looking to rent your houses out
to housing associations go on google
type in the name of your area birmingham
warsaw coventry leeds manchester london
followed by housing association get the
phone and call every single housing
association one by one and say hey i've
got a house are you looking for more
houses they'll probably say oh yes we
are because the council have got more
people to give us but we just need the
houses
show them your house and ask them how
much money can you give me for this
house
there's people even
there's very clever people
that are doing rent to rent with housing
associations so they're finding people
like me and saying i'll pay you a
thousand pounds a month rent i got
someone doing this someone came to me
with a house i've got this house in
birmingham they said i'll pay you a
thousand pounds a month i said
i said i want 1100 they're like cool
i'll give you 1100 a month for the whole
house i'm like cool they then go to a
housing association the housing
association pays them 1500. they're
making 300 pounds a month
every month for five years for doing
nothing just for introducing me to a
housing association that's smart so
that's what housing associations are
that's what assisted living is and
supported living is if you've got
questions comment below share this video
tell the world let's let people know how
this works because this is absolutely
fundamentally life-changing to property
investors and also it's helping
vulnerable people get off the streets
and get the care they deserve peace out
thanks for watching
[Music]